des pelles et des bottes de caoutchouc
cette famille a décidé de passer son
samedi les deux pieds dans la boue pour
prêter main forte à un ami
la personne en question
si oui qu un entraîneur de volley ball
locale une cinquantaine de personnes
sont venues l'aider à
gia
il habite tout près de l'endroit où la
digue a cédé le pont devant chez lui a
été emporté par le courant
sa maison n'a pas été épargné il avait
de l'eau jusqu'aux hanches si bien qu'il
a dû se rendre chez son voisin en canot
alors c'est cette digue qui protège les
terres agricoles d'abbotsford qui a cédé
cette semaine des camions comme celui ci
circulent sur la digue depuis plus de 24
heures sans arêtes ils viennent de la
terre de la pierre pour tenter de
colmater la brèche il faut y arriver
avant que la pluie ne revienne
la vallée du fraser et le sud de la
province déjà éprouvée pourrait recevoir
jusqu'à une centaine de millimètres de
précipitations en début de semaine
d'ici là les efforts s'organise un
nouveau contingent de militaires est
arrivé aujourd'hui les apporte entre
autres des hélicoptères pour acheminer
du carburant et de la nourriture à des
communautés isolées si le temps ne
permet que cela avec la pluie vient le
le couvert de nuages et des missions de
visibilité fait que certaines places
surtout dans les montagnes pour ce que
des hélicoptères ils ont bon dos au
progrès de monter aussi des montagnes
qui doivent vous allez à vue fait que si
la météo et moi est bonne ça ce qui peut
simplement pas y aller mais je voulais
les aujourd'hui l'heure est au nettoyage
rick se préparent aux prochaines
intempéries
ici sébastien desrosiers radio-canada a
bottle